a high court judge has ruled that  doctors can lawfully stop providing life  support treatment to 12-year-old archie  battersby after reviewing evidence at a  hearing in london and that breaking news  is just coming in to us now you'll  remember last month it was the high  court that ruled archie was brainstem  dead and that hospital treatment should  stop but then his parents they wanted to  appeal they won the right to an appeal  um for a new hearing and that hearing  was taking place on it took place on  monday the results of that hearing is in  now and that is the news the high court  judge  in that  appeal hearing has ruled that doctors  can now lawfully stop providing life  support treatment  to 12 year old archie battersby and that  was after reviewing evidence at that  hearing that is in london